et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec vikash dhorasoo ancien
joueur de l'équipe de france bonsoir
vikash dhorasoo merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés fernand duchaussoy ancien
président de la fédération française de
football bonsoir fernand duchaussoy
merci à vous aussi d'autres en direct
sur rt france donc deux équipes qui
quitte le terrain en ligue des champions
qui refusent de rejouer à de jouer la
rencontre c'est du jamais vu
c'est nouveau ça que des joueurs de
football s'exprime à ce point sur des
phénomènes de société est ce qu'il faut
l'encourager
vikash dhorasoo bas c'est une grande
grande première oui ça veut dire que dès
les jours de foot noir avant souriez
essayer de montrer l'indifférence face
aux aux racistes qui pouvaient subir et
cette fois ils ont refusé ils ont bombé
le torse et ils sont sortis du terrain
et ils ont emmené avec avec eux les deux
équipes de façon solidaire tout le monde
est sorti et a refusé ce qui se passe et
c'était aussi des hauts-pays désobéir à
l'autorité désobéir à l'instance
dirigeante qui est l'uefa qu'il fait pas
grand chose sur ce sujet et donc c'est
un moment très très fort parce
qu'évidemment aujourd'hui sa marque un
tournant ça veut dire que si ça se
reproduit l'uefa la fédération française
de foot la ligue de football pour faire
toutes ces instances qui dirige qu'ils
font rien sauront que les joueurs de
foot pourront quitter le terrain
quitteront le terrain hier le spectacle
télévisuel s'était arrêté ça c'est très
grave pour le football si demain on
stoppe un match de foot c'est à dire que
match débat diffusé quitté n'arrive pas
à les sponsors sont pas contents c'est
ce qui peut arriver de pire à bôle qui
passe à la télé c'est vrai que c'est un
angle qui est intéressant ce que vous
nous dites parce qu'on a beaucoup
débattu aujourd'hui voilà sur ce qu'il
fallait
voilà ce que ça valait le coup est ce
que c'était sûr réagir mais ce que vous
nous dites c'est que là c'est peut-être
la goutte pas là peut-être pas la plus
grave est en tout cas la goutte qui a
fait déborder l'eau du vase et que
désormais il ya un pouvoir qu'ont les
joueurs et une marge de manoeuvre très
importante fernand duchaussoy duchaussoy
pardon sur les institutions di vikash
dhorasoo qui ne font rien vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse
donc il y avait dirigé la plus grande en
france je pense et aura six qui sont
tenus il ya pratiquement mené dans donc
à nouveau acquitté
je pense que ça a été la goutte d'eau
qui a fait déborder pas pareil alors
c'est vrai qu'on a un petit point de
liaison on espère que ça va se rétablir
avec fernand duchaussoy avant longtemps
voilà que c'est sauf trahir vos paroles
parce qu'on savait qu'on entendait un
mot sur deux que ce sont des actes
malheureusement récurrent dans le
football vous propose pourtant d'écouter
ce qu'a dit noël le graet ans c'était le
15 septembre dernier le président celui
qui vous ai succédé donc le président de
la fédération française de football sur
les questions de racisme dans le foot
écouter quentin blake marque un but tout
le stade est debout
le phénomène raciste dans le sport et
dans le football en particulier n'existe
pas ou peu vikash dhorasoo de réaction
bailly monsieur le graët tu nous fait
regarder ailleurs il faut regarder à
l'endroit où c'est pas là que ça se
passe je dire derrière le but
il ya déjà des cris racistes des des
cris de singe et voilà on considère que
le noir est content et comparer un
animal voilà l'homme blanc était
supérieure à l'homme noir et mais qu'il
faut le regarder c'est peut-être aussi
dans la tribune présidentielle moi ce
que je remarque c'est que le sait le
système créé ce racisme il ya racisme
systémique
pourquoi il n'y a pas d'entraîneur noir
dans le milieu du football
aujourd'hui il n'a pas il n'y a aucun
entraîneur noir alors que plus de la
moitié des joueurs sur les terrains de
football sont issus de l'immigration
voire arabe et d'autres qui donnent
parfois du brésil asiatiques et il y en
a aucun quand les instances dirigeantes
il y en a aucun chez les arbitres il n'y
en a pas dans dans les syndicats je
crois qu'il ya une femme à la fédération
française de foot qui est laura georges
il n'y en a pas du tout sur les terrains
sur les bancs de touche donc comme
entraîneur donc là il ya un vrai
problème de dire on a imposé la parité
pour qu'il y ait des femmes qui
commencent à émerger à prendre d avoir
des positions fortes dans le monde dans
le monde politique notamment
il n'y a rien qui fait qu' on peut
accéder à des postes importants quand on
est à un ancien joueur de foot fernand
duchaussoy ya deux informations que sur
lesquelles je voulais vous faire réagir
déjà ce que nous dit votre successeur à
noël le graet ya pas en gros de racisme
dans le foot ou pas beaucoup même si
noël le graet aujourd'hui à condamner
ces propos à sur cette affaire et
d'autre part voilà une forme de racisme
même dans les coulisses ya pas de
l'homme de couleur noah dans les
instances dirigeantes du foot est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous contestez
que vous avez pu remarquer vous à votre
époque et qui est de faire encore
aujourd'hui
mais quand j'étais candidat quand moment
sur ma liste et puis j'avais jamais le
sandjak donc
j'avais bien entendu essayé de que tous
ces centaines de milliers de gamins qui
sont sur le terrain de football puissent
être représentés dans les instances
supérieures
voilà quelle a été ma démarche donc
c'est sûr qu'il ya beaucoup moins et pas
suffisamment effectivement vikash
rappeler aussi de femmes notamment dans
la région il au district artois c'est
une femme qui est devenue présidente de
district il y en a eu aussi dans la
nièvre
mais c'est évidemment pas suffisant et
surtout dans les instances on a
énormément de personnes issues de
français qui sont représentants comme
vikash et d'autres sur les terrains ils
sont pas suffisamment et pas du tout
représentés j'avais le dire sur le dans
les instances qui dirige le football
français ça c'est totalement un homme
alors c'est vrai qu'on a vu des scènes
insoutenables dans les jets de bananes
les cris de singes qui deviennent de
plus en plus fréquentes dans certains
stades et l'a finalement ce qui met le
feu aux poudres c'est un mot en roumain
negro on a compris après voilà ça
voulait dire noir et pa negro donc
ça n'a pas exactement la même
connotation vikash dhorasoo est ce qu'on
a sur réagi où finalement non ça valait
cela ça valait 1 départ du terrain des
joueurs j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans
un débat si je ne suis pas aux mains je
parle mais ce qui est sûr et certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça ne passe plus je
veux dire j'entendais hier claude
makelele qui commentait son époque et
qui me disait quand moi je avec violence
raciste à mon égard je souriais je monte
j'étais indifférent
et puis aussi savait que si ça a été a
été vécu un jeu des rabais soit d'eau
qui s'était plaint à l'arbitré avait
pris un carton rouge c'était à metz il
ya quelques années
ba aujourd'hui les jours de foot il
refuse ça ils n'acceptent pas en watts
les joueurs de foot comme le jus coule
des ou où elle va et qui prennent des
positions très fortes antiraciste
notamment face aux violences policières
et après ce que disait monsieur
duchaussoy aussi ce qui est très
important
c'est que si les joueurs de foot
n'accepte pas aux postes de décision de
important de pouvoir et ben comment on
peut regarder autrement le port de foot
noir sur le terrain que juste un mec qui
cire le système qui est là pour courir
mais qui n'a pas de cerveau c'est pour
ça qu'on le compare sans arrêt à les
cris de singe cet état mais parce que
ces jours là eux aussi pas des diplômes
et eux aussi ont les capacités d
entraîner d'avoir des données des postes
à responsabilité il faut leur donner la
possibilité d'y accéder il faut pas que
ce soit fermé et c'est ce système là
qu'il faut maintenant remettre tout en
cause voilà c'est parce qu'à du le graet
c'est pas de l'homme s'il le système
fernand duchaussoy
vous y croyez vous à ce changement de
deux systèmes aujourd'hui le système
est-il mur pour ceux là où il va être
contraint justement par des joueurs qui
disent maintenant long c'est fini on va
quitter le terrain à chaque fois que il
y aura voilà des propos racistes
racistes présumés on ne sait pas mais ça
va se passer comme ça désormais il y
aura un tournant oui je pense qu'il ya
un tournant extrêmement important hier
il s'est passé comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure alors qu'il ya déjà eu des
matches où il ya eu des propos racistes
sur le terrain ou venant des tribunes
plus vous plus fréquemment encore vous
allez cité tout à l'heure des jets de
bananes etc
ce qui est évidemment terriblement
scandaleux
donc les choses ne pourront plus tout à
fait ce passé j'espère que
définitivement comme ça se passait
précédemment
parce que il faut se battre il faut
absolument se battre contre ce racisme
qui gangrène le sport en général et le
football en particulier
alors je dis pas que c'est massif alors
c'est compliqué pour le football parce
que c'est aussi un creuset
extraordinaire d'intégration entre et
d'humanité entre entre les joueurs mais
d'un autre côté pour le moindre incident
on a tout de suite des propos qui
dépasse l entendement on parlait tout à
l'heure des goûts on sait pas trop ce
que ça veut dire
je suis un peu comme vikash je suis pas
inclus roumain donc je peux pas je peux
pas dire la traduction de ce moment en
tout cas pas vraiment dans un maillot
lui fait faire à mon avis on parle on
parle anglais je pense que c'est
obligatoire
les arbitres sont obligés de parler on
était quand on désigne quelqu'un dans
l'assistance d'abord on dit monsieur
parce que vikash ne contribuera pas à
chaque fois qu'ils s'adressent et la
victime monsieur les arbitres et il n'y
a pas de raison que les arbitres eux
mêmes ne disent pas à des entraîneurs ou
des entraîneurs adjoints ou et des
joueurs monsieur untel ou monsieur untel
et c'est la moindre des politesses et on
désigne par les gens dans une tribune
sur leur apparence physique avec h
dhorasoo dernière question effectivement
ça paraît idiot mais peut-être qu'il
faudrait instaurer tout simplement une
langue unique à tout le monde comme dans
l'aérien pour ne pas risquer les les
malentendus et et ce genre d'affaires
c'est une bonne idée non mais parce
qu'en fait on est en train de
de nous faire croire que on pourrait
quoi voilà que c'est un peu langue de
communication et moi j'arrête pas de
vous dire je vous le redis encore c'est
un système qui qu'il faut changer
il ya là pour le coup il y avait
personne dans la tribune donc ça venait
pas des tribunes c'est venu du système
c'est devenu c'est venu de dés des
arbitres qui sont les envoyés de ceux
qui dirigent c'est-à-dire l'uefa donc ça
veut dire que c'est vraiment un système
là c'est pas les supporters qui de
chacun de leur côté commença à jeter des
bananes ou lançaient des cris de singe
merci en tout cas à tous les deux vikash
dhorasoo fernand duchaussoy d'avoir été
avec nous pour évoquer donc cette
affaire entre qui s'est produite donc
lors du match psg bat chaque ceir merci
à vous deux